of course I miss my babies did you dress
at home or you went away no I got ready
at a room around the corner actually
because I think that it's my kids like
to pick sequins off of things and this
would have been very dangerous yeah yeah
the dress would have been a giant yarn
didn't you never ever want to be in a
position where you have to tell them
back up I would so I got out of the
house how are you guys balancing all
this stuff you're doing with two
children only one of us works at a time
we have a lot of great people that are
our support system and we bring our kids
everywhere to work my babies come to
work every day as a luxury of doing that
yeah we just were very mindful about
taking jobs that will take us away from
them today so Dax is at home with the
baby yes
stays home no more like oh let's go
together does he miss this stuff at all
or not no he doesn't like dressing up so
he's he's much more comfortable just in
his cutoff jeans and his tank top at
home with the kids
you